-Welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
I'm very excited about this.
Megan Thee Stallion
is my co-host tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Megan Thee Stallion.
Just a reminder
to our viewers at home -- to get
the full Megan experience,
go ahead and press
the W-A-P button on your remote.
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to some news.
I saw that President Biden
just kicked off
a seven-day summer vacation
in South Carolina.
Yeah, South Carolina.
Right now, Delaware is like,
"Oh, looks like
Mr. 40% in approval rating's
too good for us now, huh?"
[ Laughter ]
Biden is relaxing
in South Carolina.
You know some
White House staffer's like,
"Freaking guy takes 18 sick days
and then he goes
on a seven-day vacation.
Must be nice."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Must be nice
to be the president.
Oh, must be nice."
-[ Laughing ]
-Well,
people are talking about this.
Yesterday,
former President Trump
was deposed
by New York attorney general,
and he chose to plead the fifth.
And then he just replied,
"Same answer,"
to every question.
[ Laughter ]
And it happened -- he did it
for, like, four hours.
But I don't really see how
that could really happen.
I mean, you know, keep saying
the same answer all the time.
Uh, by the way, Tariq,
I keep meaning to ask you,
what are you gonna do
this weekend?
-Break.
-Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Also, how do you
slow down a car?
-Same answer.
[ Laughter ]
-What happened to those cool
red glasses you used to wear?
-Same answer.
[ Laughter ]
-How do you eat a Kit Kat?
-Eh, same answer.
[ Laughter ]
-What do waves do?
-Same answer.
[ Laughter ]
-And what happened to your arm?
-Same answer.
[ Laughter continues ]
-What's that movie
I'm thinking of?
"Point..."
-Same answer!
-How do detectives solve cases?
-Same answer.
-What were Ross and Rachel on?
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
They were obviously dating,
Jimmy.
He broke her heart.
He broke her heart!
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Tariq Trotter, everybody.
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my gosh.
-Double thumbs up.
Hey, guys, listen to this.
Today in North Korea,
Kim Jong-un
declared victory against COVID.
[ Laughter ]
All right.
It looks like
my end-of-summer-vacation plans
are back on.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
To celebrate the victory,
Kim Jong-un held a huge parade,
and then everyone
got COVID again.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of COVID,
the CEO of Moderna said that
vaccines for the virus
will evolve like an iPhone.
[ Laughter ]
Let me translate that
for you guys.
So, the COVID vaccine
now costs $1,100.
[ Laughter ]
-Some entertainment news --
Disney+ just announced details
on their new
ad-supported option,
which is called
Disney+ Basic.
[ Laughter ]
Can I just get
Disney minus the insults?
You know what I'm saying?
I just feel --
Disney+ Basic.
It's like Disney+,
but it's super into Uggs
and pumpkin spice.
[ Laughter ]
It sounds more like
a mean thing a princess --
a Disney Princess
would call Barbie.
"She's Disney+ Basic."
[ Laughter ]
This is interesting.
I saw that the show "Pennyworth"
on HBO Max has been renamed
"Pennyworth: The Origin
of Batman's Butler."
[ Laughter ]
Well, HBO Max
is actually introducing
a bunch of new shows, too.
For example, first there's
"Dave: The Origins of Batman's
Butler Pennyworth's Friend."
[ Laughter ]
Then there's
"Vinny: The Origins of Batman's
Butler Pennyworth's Friend
Dave's Roommate."
[ Laughter ]
Then they have
"Carl: The Origins of Batman's
Butler Pennyworth's Friend
Dave's Roommate Vinny's
Brother-in-Law Who's Doing
Pretty Well for Himself,
Dude Has an In-Ground Pool,
Whaaat?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally --
that should have been finally.
[ Both laugh ]
Finally, "Carl's Butler:
The Origins of Batman's Butler
Pennyworth's Friend
Dave's Roommate Vinny's
Brother-in-Law Carl's Butler,
Who is Actually
Pennyworth Again.
Remember Him?"
That's it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
A long name, but I get it.
Smart.
You guys hear about this?
There's a new dating app
for conservatives
coming out soon
that's called The Right Stuff.
[ Laughter ]
Unfortunately, people will go
on a lot of bad dates
because they refuse
to swipe left.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh! Hey!
[ Applause ]
-When guys on the app are asked
what their actual height is,
they plead the fifth.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, guys, I --
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You know --
You know what that sound means.
Megan Thee Stallion
is co-hosting!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my goodness!
-Hello!
-Oh, I love you.
Look at that!
Come on!
That's Megan Thee Stallion.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi!
-Megan Thee Stallion!
-Hello!
-Come on, welcome!
-Come on!
-That's good. All right.
We got a long show.
We've got a lot --
We got a lot of show.
-Okay.
And, yeah, we got to hurry
this monologue up.
-Okay -- I agree.
-Okay.
-So I'm just gonna quickly
go through the rest of it,
and you can give me quick
reactions to each one.
-Okay, let's do it.
-Okay.
-Joe Biden
started a seven-day vacation.
-Classy.
[ Laughter ]
-Pumpkin spice
has already arrived.
-Bougie.
[ Laughter ]
-Trump supporters are waving
flags outside Mar-A-Lago.
-Ratchet.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-The new season of "Below Deck."
[ Laughter ]
-Sassy.
-Simon Cowell's "AGT's" a hit.
-Moody.
[ Laughter ]
-Officials in Florida
asked people to stop
messing with manatees
that are mating.
-Nasty.
[ Laughter ]
-During yesterday's deposition,
Trump repeated the word
"same answer" for four hours.
-Acting stupid.
What happening?
-That's exactly --
There you have it.
That's correct.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is correct.
You have it, right there.
-Exactly!
-All right.
How about we tell some jokes?
You down?
-Okay, let's do it.
-All right, great.
Here we go.
This is funny.
A mother in New Jersey
celebrated her daughter's
graduation by renting
a billboard with her face on it.
This is real.
Take a look at this.
That's nice.
Also, a little bit embarrassing.
-Yes. Graduation?
-Yes, exactly.
But it's a little embarrassing.
But not as embarrassing as these
other billboards that I saw.
First there's --
Look at this one.
"Rob, congrats
on graduating high school,
and happy 35th birthday."
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's sad.
-Okay.
-Give me one.
-Okay. And then there's,
"Lucy, remember that time
you hit reply all?
'Cause I do."
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
-Next, there's,
"Andrew, you did it!
You got hemorrhoids."
[ Audience groans ]
On a billboard.
-Okay.
And finally...
[ Laughter ]
"R.I.P. Amanda.
If you see this, call me.
I have bad news.
Love, Dr. Brown."
-That's a terrible billboard
to see.
-Terrible billboard.
-Terrible billboard to see.
Finally, guys, everyone's
traveling this summer,
and I read that the most
mispronounced places
in the United States are
Louisville, Spokane, and Boise.
-Okay.
-Come on.
Those are easy.
I never mispronounce any places
'cause you're looking at
a professional announcer.
Go ahead, try me.
-I mean, I guess I can test you
real quick, if you want.
What's this city?
-Easy.
Cheesecake.
[ Laughter ]
-How about this city?
-Burning Man. Come on.
Give me some harder ones.
[ Laughter ]
You gotta rapid-fire me.
-Rapid fire.
Okay, I'm not sure
that's a great idea,
but here we go.
How about these cities?
-Okay.
Pepsi-Cola.
[ Laughter ]
Lululemon.
Beyoncé.
-Yes!
-Bloomin' Onion.
[ Laughter ]
"Sex and the City."
Harry Belafonte.
[ Laughter ]
Dave Coulier, damn.
Hadouken!
-Yes!
-Nipples.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, Banana Penis. Mm.
Mini-penis.
[ Laughter ]
My Anus.
Man's Asses.
[ Laughter ]
And Masturbates-ville.
-All right, all right.
Stop, stop. That's plenty.
Enough. That's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay, wait.
-That's more than enough.
Higgins is right.
This is easy.
I want to do some.
-Sure, you can try that one,
if you want to.
-Boom.
[ Laughter ]
Easy.
Vagina.
[ Laughter ]
-How about this one?
-West Vagina.
-All right, stop, stop, stop.
All right, let's just stop.
I don't want
to play this game anymore.